Paula Reid has been covering the Cohen
case since it began and she is here with
me this morning Paula
lots of questions let's get through them
if he weren't President of the United
States would Donald Trump have been
indicted alongside Michael Cohen very
likely yes because federal prosecutors
are alleging that he had personal
involvement in the commission of a
felony so if they had evidence that he
did it knowingly willfully then yes it's
likely he'd be charged now that we know
that the president of United States was
in the room when it was decided to pay
off stormy Daniels what does that mean
about the president's involvement it's
further evidence that he had knowledge
of these payments that he likely
directed these payments and this was
done in an effort to help his chances in
the election but Nora my big question is
what else did they discuss in that
meeting
Kellyanne Conway says there's no proof
that this was done in order to influence
the election is that true well let's
look at the timing here right the
Daniels payment that was done around the
same time as they Access Hollywood tapes
it would appear that his decision to pay
her at that time was part of an effort
to prevent any more stories that could
potentially do lethal damage to his
chances in the election it's all about
timing key question do we know did the
Special Counsel Robert Muller asked
President Trump if he knew about this
payment to stormy Daniels
I asked it for one of the president's
attorneys about this I could not get an
answer they would not disclose but Nora
this is his greatest vulnerability in
the special counsel invest Ahnold Trump
lied to Robert Muller about his
involvement with this payment and
whether he knew about this payment what
would that mean that could potentially
be referred to Congress or possible
impeachment it's not a crime to lie on
Twitter it's not a crime to lie to
reporters and Air Force One it is a
crime to lie to federal investigators
all right Paula Reid thank you